hello everyone and welcome to another
Wild game uh from the final round of
this year's Norway chess Blitz uh so
first days Blitz then the rest we have
the classical tournament you know the
classical game followed by an Armageddon
game if the classical game ends in a
drawn and which is uh has a very very
special uh format uh each year uh but
this game is uh very important as it
decides the winner of the tournament now
we've already seen one game we've seen
how Lucas defeated Magnus Carlsen
yesterday on his birthday and here in
the final round he faces Notre bak and
sorry for some reason uh I uh I I almost
put another box rating as um almost 9
000 uh so let me just fix that
I have no idea where this number came
from it's uh like it's it's a really
weird number
uh but there we go sorry about that uh
so it's a it's a really incredible game
you guys will enjoy it uh let's check it
out so another big has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to E4 we have
Pawn to C5 uh Google shops for the
Sicilian Defense 923 Knight to C6 and
now Knight to C3 uh we have Pawn to E6
and we transpose into the standard stuff
captures captures the time on a
variation and now the Bostick of Queen
to C7 uh Bishop to E3 and now Pawn to A6
and here uh there are many uh popular
continuations Queen to D2 being the most
popular one Bishop to E2 Bishop to D3
another way goes for Queen to F3 it's uh
sort of the fourth most popular
continuation and you know that once the
knights the E5 lands you're not going to
be going back you're gonna be going to
to G3 then you're gonna be putting
pressure on the queen and the G7 Pawn so
it's a very forced line but as it is
with all the force lines it's fairly
easy to defend against them because you
you have a very uh general idea of what
why is doing so Knight to F6 we have
Castle's Queen side and now Knight the
E5 attacking the queen queen to G3 uh
x-raying the queen on C7 also hindering
the development of the dark Square
Bishop on f8 but this is all very well
known stuff so Goku just continues his
expansion on the queen Side Pawn to B5
Knight back to F3 now putting pressure
on the E5 Knight and just Pawn to D6 and
here another big captures an E5 Knight
captures an e5d captures and okay it's
um maybe a small victory for a while
because you've messed up black spawn
structure you've doubled his Central
pawns on the other hand a white uh
almost always wants to put an ID on the
E5 and here you're not going to be able
to do that on D5 or or on F5 or you know
if if you're really into attacking you
will do it uh you know regardless of
that but uh it's it's definitely a
trade-off and here there are no moves
like if A3 has been played here F4 has
been played here uh here uh noted by
ghost for Ponte F3 it has only been
played once and we are going to get to
that Bishop to D7 Bishop to D3 and none
there was a game in the European
individual championship in 2018 uh
pacovejo headed against Martin
bossiercich where Rook the C8 was played
in that game uh ended by both switch
winning but here we have upon the B4
chasing away the Knight and it is now as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game so Knight back to E2 and now Pawn
to A5 gookish continues the attack on
the queen side and just King to B1 uh
it's uh it's hard to see how exactly
another bag will start his own attack on
the king side as the black king is still
in the center of the board his Queen is
on G3 so he can't play G4 G5 so what is
he to do well Pawn to A4 gookish
continues his attack on the queen side
and now Rook the C1 saying okay if you
ever played B3 I'm just gonna capture it
and your queen will be under attack so
G6 uh Google says all right I'm just
gonna castle since you're not really
attacking me or anything Queen to F2
moving the queen now you can push h4h G4
uh Bishop to D6 if you push A3 just B3
and it's very hard to grab hold of this
diagonal for gookish as the Knight and
the bishop are doing such a fine job so
he is uh holding on with that uh better
not
as spoil it by executing it too early we
have Bishop to D6 Ponte H4 and just
stopping further expansion with Ponte H5
we have Bishop to G5 attacking the
Knight and the blue cash defense Bishop
to E7 we have Queen to G3 uh and now
Bishop to C6 uh and now comes Knight to
D4 there are many moves you can play
here like you could play Rook H to D1 or
something like that but Knight the D4 is
the uh the the human move uh that that
everyone wants to play because it puts
pressure on the bishop and also this is
impossible uh the queen on C7 is still
undefended so Knights the D7 glucose
just over straight everything down
Bishop captures King captures and now
only now Rook H to D1 we have Rook H to
d8 and now Pawn to C3 preparing to open
up the C file for the white Rook
upon the B3 Gucci prevents that and now
Pawn to A3 another back also stops any
opening of the queen side with Queen to
B6 uh and now uh Queen to G5 with check
with King the D6 here uh your best uh
um move is King to f8 actually and now
after let's say why trade with a knight
captures Queen captures G4 and okay
looks looks scary but black can defend
however after Queen to G5 check uh
has played King to D6 he wanted to hide
his King on the queen side but this just
a blunders um uh the game so feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
another back while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
beautiful uh double x-ray move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is night the B5 with check as
you can see here The Rook is x-raying
the black king here but the problem is
there's a knight and the bishop in
between so what do you do you move the
Knight with Tempo Knights the B5 with
check and it also prevents the king from
escaping the C7 so you can't really go
back the queen covers that and you can't
go to C5 because Queen to E7 will be
Checkmate so your only option is to
capture it and you kind of should
capture it with the bishop if you don't
want to part with your queen too early
so Bishop captures some B5 Bishop
capture is now opening up a discovery
from The Rook King to C7 and now Bishop
captures on D7 uh just removing the
defender of the E5 Pawn Rook captures
Queen captures an E5 with check King to
C6 and now Rook to D4 with all sorts of
nasty threats for example if if you just
trade here which you kind of want to do
because you're under attack uh King to
B7 and now Rook C4 by Rook to B4 this is
game over so after Rook to D4 Rook the
A5 was played attacking the queen on E5
but now
and not Rebecca gains access to the to
the back rank he goes Queen to h8 so
Rook a back to A7 and now Rook the C4
with check with King to D6 and now Queen
to f8 with check think the E5 and Rook
the C5 with check with King to F6 if you
go down the board with Queen to F4 it's
a fairly uh simple Checkmate Queen to H6
checking to G3 and now Queen to E3
followed by Pawn to F4 and that's uh
pretty much it of course uh uh players
are missing most of the the critical
lines because this is Blitz and they
only have a few seconds on the clock but
they uh Do Spot some other winning lines
so yeah of course if you have a few
seconds on the clock you're not going to
waste them trying to look for that
perfect uh sequence so King to F6 uh and
now Pawn to G for E5 check is
um also straight up winning so G4 was
played now comes upon the E5 stopping E5
by another back and now Queen to h8 with
check here we actually have a mating
four I'm just gonna show it because it's
a lot of funky 26 Queen T8 with check
only move Rook D7 or you can or okay you
can go to D6 but then Queen captures and
E5 is Checkmate so you have to block
Here and Now Rook C6 check Queen
captures and queen captures is also
Checkmate so after E5 Queen to h8 check
will be played King to E7 and now Rook
captures an E5 with check King to D6 uh
Rook the D5 with check King to C6 and
now Queen to F6 with check and now
uh there's really nothing to do if you
go to B7 you lose the Rook here and if
you don't uh well you're just gonna lose
the queen so after Queen to F6 check it
was in this uh position on move 40 uh
that goukash resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here the
problem is that once you uh move the
king let's say you defend the Rook you
can just play Rook captures on C7 with
the check and the D7 will check after
King captures You're Gonna Lose the
queen or pretty much any of the other
lines are also uh completely winning
form uh for another back uh so yeah
another big wins the game and not just
the game he wins the entire tournament
we thought that it was going to be
gookish who will be fighting for first
place because he uh just crushed Magnus
Carlsen in the game that we've seen uh
but uh uh as you can see Lucas finished
last with two and a half points and it's
actually Abu satro after winning this
game against bukash who is alone in
first place six out of nine points then
with five and a half out of nine we have
alireza Fury with five and a half out of
nine Fabiano caruana Wesley so and
Hikaru Nakamura four and a half Magnus
Carlsen in seventh place this is his
worst result yet in norwich's Blitz an
issue with three and a half Aryan tari
with two and a half and Gucci with two
and a half so it's not about just having
fun before the classical tournament
starts or can we even call it a
classical as every classical game has a
an Armageddon tiebreaker so it's sort of
a classical Armageddon tournament or or
maybe you guys have a fine word for that
I don't know uh but yeah it's not just
for fun uh those who do really well in
the tournament will get two whites um in
the tournament uh so uh an extra white
in the tournament uh so that you know
that definitely goes a long way even
though you know uh if if you check the
results from classical games it's not
that white is winning that often if
anything black is winning more games so
I don't know if if that makes even sense
nowadays because the the the the the the
art of Defense has progressed so much
that it could even be like better to be
black everyone wants to play White uh
it's just that uh they more often than
not do better with black
uh but yeah who knows we'll see what
happens uh very much looking forward to
the classical event uh big
congratulations to another Beck on
winning this I mean ahead of this
spectacular field we'll see how he does
in the classical and uh you know I hope
you guys will enjoy it as well uh so
yeah that's the game really hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Marcus
grabble Bunty ravishing reptiles YouTube
Mikhail zakarias and David gasparian for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of Norway chess until it
finishes uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day